ladies and gentlemen of the reject nation we
are going to talk about a subject that i'm sure
will be sensitive for many leave your thoughts
down below on what you think about all this if
you've already heard and if you haven't heard
we'll go through it all and we'll give our
thoughts we are talking about oscar fan favorite
cheer movement zack snyder did they deserve it
i know we're talking about ezra miller today it's
being reported uh by rolling stone warner brothers
held an emergency meeting about the actor's
future with the company the meeting was to discuss
pausing all future projects involving ezra
miller and that toilet got a lot of thoughts
in the bathroom over there as well as any public
appearance involving the actor himself and this
is coming hot off the heels of of many alarming
things needless to say so you might have heard
recently that he was arrested and and you know in
fairness that's it wasn't a bad mug shot you know
no it was a great it was a great shot people have
to be lucky to have that mug celebrity mug shots
can be a nasty business and i was like you know
what at least he got a not so bad if it was a
bad mug shot this situation probably would
have been way worse honestly you know this
the situation of a mug shot can be so much more
telling of just how bad he was in that moment
he looks like the way we react it looks like
they got time to to prepare for their bug shot
so where this stem from was according to reports
miller became agitated while at a karaoke bar
grabbed the microphone from a woman singing and
then reportedly lunged after an another man who
was playing darts the couple filed a restraining
order against miller and then the article goes on
says miller reportedly threatened to burn a couple
in hawaii last week according to court documents
surrounding their arrest i don't know how to
process them i am so sorry stoion kojokariff and
his wife nigel hayes filed a temporary restraining
order against miller after alleging that miller
burst into their bedroom and threatened to burn
them and of course i'm sure many of you already
remember the whole situation years ago what
feels like or was it a year ago i don't know
where ezra miller was caught on camera choking
a female fan i've had some people say it was
it was just a stunt it was a goof i've heard
other people say that it wasn't he got aggressive
and that they probably paid that woman to not do
anything about it the thing is i don't know and
you probably don't know because they never said
[ __ ] about it so we don't know interested
we don't know what happened right and i thought
it was bizarre with this whole thing with warner
brothers of the the firing and all the drama
like every time we talk about warner brothers
i feel like there's some weird dramas slanted with
them right there's like stained with that a lot of
people who've been fired or been replaced a lot of
people felt it was unjust or unfair and then other
people who got to keep working that they thought
was unfair and ezra miller they were like let's
just not say anything we can't afford another one
of these and now it seems like that people are
finally actually saying something and i do think
he should be held accountable for his actions
these are very violent displays of behavior and
it sounds like a man who is quite neurotic uh like
i don't know this man 99.9 percent of you guys
don't know this man either sounds like he has some
real like mental health struggles that
he has to deal with and so he needs help
and at the same time if just because a person
has mental health struggles just because they
are suffering with something to give the
benefit of the doubt in that regard i mean
it seems pretty obvious that doesn't give an
excuse to the behavior nor should he just be
allowed to get a pass on this it totally makes
sense to me because this behavior is on going
this is a continuous thing like that choking fan
incident i don't remember how long ago that was
but enough time has passed to get to the point
where ezra miller could have you know done enough
work on himself to not be attacking people right
yeah instead of allowing it to get that much worse
you know like i i think about coming off of the
heels of will smith physically assaulting chris
rock he assaulted individuals and the amount of
condemnation that people have thrown will smith
you know like well fair is fair ezra miller should
definitely be really condemned for these actions
then too if we're pausing upcoming will smith
joints we should absolutely be pausing upcoming
ezra miller joints yeah because the article's not
saying they discussed like replacing him or firing
him even though that's what this heavily alludes
to i feel like he really got away with it before
and he can't just get away with it again that's
basically where i'm standing with this well maybe
we're at the point now too where love of the
snyder verse will no longer eclipse just like
needing to address bad behavior yeah like the
whole movement is about accountability part of
it is about accountability over entertainment so
now that's also being reported that there was some
insider on the on the side of the flash who said
they didn't reveal who said this so maybe it's
just a rumor that he was having like a lot of sort
of mental breakdowns while on set like apparently
ezra would get a thought in his head and be like i
don't know what i'm doing in his defense i i feel
like they haven't known what they're doing
with that flash movie for the longest time
well i mean in isolation that would seem like yeah
a set that would be enough to drive anybody into
sort of a confusing mixed up place or whatever or
maybe yeah equate to some weird onset behavior but
this does smack of a situation that has only
boiled over and gotten worse because it's like
with the removal of time from the choking incident
like if nothing else had ever happened i would be
inclined to believe like oh yeah maybe it was
some kind of weird prank between somebody he
had it they had a connection with that i i know
nothing about but now it does feel more like
the ladder of like maybe they paid that person
to keep quiet in hopes they could contain this
and it's just not working out i mean i saw a tweet
from ryan airy this afternoon kind of identifying
it as addict behavior and i could absolutely
imagine that and that's something that you
know you can't really control on your own after
a certain amount of time and when you're under
this much pressure and in the position of such
notoriety and such attention from everyone around
you know it's only a matter of time before all
that boils over the way he's talked about his
past experiences from the little glimpses i've
been able to gather it sounds like he's had some
type of you know traumatic but anyone who displays
this kind of behavior obviously would have some
type of traumatic unresolved things he has to deal
with and yeah talking about the whole thing with
addiction a lot of this is theoretical and a lot
of it is probable regardless that he has to be
held accountable for this stuff and i don't know
what the decision is for it like you can't just
replace him in in the flash movie at the same time
like they need to freaking finish this damn movie
and weirdly i'm like well if there is a character
you could replace i feel like you could actually
replace the flash like i've heard fans already
being like they should have just made grand gusts
in him in the dc and i'm like well yeah you're
doing a multiverse movie so sure just you know
get a different actor to play the flash they've
already had like 14 batman's going on two of them
alone are in this one movie so i'm like sure we'll
get a different flash actor i think it's so odd of
how they've been so tight-lipped it just seemed
like he wouldn't suffer any repercussions for
this type of behavior and i don't feel like this
is just another thing of like will culture cancel
culture like no this is uh this is not okay people
have to be held to equal standards especially in
the parent company and warner brothers so i don't
feel like he should just get a pass on all this
and it's crazy it sounds like they have like
so many things lined up with him and to begin
with the fantastic beasts movie that's coming
out and then you know of course the flash movie
as well and of course with that there's
probably future projects in development to use
ezra miller as well well not to mention that
this flash has three versions of ezra so it's
like triple the johnny depp problem all in one
movie plus you've got dumbledore to worry about
you know i mean i guess the question is is
like the forgiveness scale of celebrities
ways depending on whoever the individual is that
is casting judgment right for me i cannot talk
about like what i feel is appropriate to do if
he actually you know is doing the actual work
to better himself if he if he is an alcoholic or
something if he is going to rehab if he is getting
some intensive therapy to truly work through
these issues you know like he's a young guy he's
only like 29 or something like that he's had a lot
of success and the way he talked about things he's
uh it sounds like he's had a lot of traumatic
experiences he grew up in the entertainment
industry which for many child actors is really
troubling times so it's not far-fetched to me
that he would have an aggressive behavior it's
it's not far-fetched again though not excusable
the thing is is that there has to be some type
of display of actual homework put in you can't
just say i'll change or release some statement
apologizing i feel like the right thing to do is
to be an inspiration in the same way how we were
able to like see robert downey jr in a new light
if someone would like oh wow their problems
were really front and center but look at them
now and i think ezra miller kind of needs to do a
similar thing i don't feel like we can just enable
him yeah and it feels like they're in a position
where if ezra miller does make the right choices
and does agree to maybe address some of this
behavior you know they could run their flash movie
take a break from that character for a little
while and then either reinstate or correct
down the road with whatever that movie establishes
because i mean to me i'm sitting here as thinking
about wb they seem to have a track record of
being finicky when it comes to how to progress
with their dc films especially films in general
sometimes especially on the big franchise scale
so i'm sitting here wondering i know they've had
to have gone well do we need to recast again how
do we not have to scrap this entire movie and
it seems like a lot of that could also come
down to whatever ezra miller and you know his camp
decides to do their camp decides to do so it does
present a sort of fascinating and very woeful
juncture for wb to me because it's like they're
just trying to get their dc universe back
on track and it seems like it's gotten to a
point where they maybe wanted to keep this as
silent as possible and just can't anymore and
so i don't envy the position that they're in
because it seems like it's a mess for everyone
patron of the day shout out yeah guys
what do you think is the proper course
of action here so should he be i feel like he
has to disappear from the spotlight for a while
you can't keep a guy like that in the spotlight
you know and expect him to really grow and change
going around the world doing pressing yeah things
nah oh a thousand percent but all right guys
i love ending these videos
thanks for being here bye